[Music]
this episode is brought to you by helix
sleep last year I focused on
dramatically improving a few things
surprise surprise
most notably the quality of my sleep
which seems to affect just about
everything this led me to revisit you
name it
my daily routine morning routine
exercise diet all the way to what I
slept on and I ended up getting all new
beds here in Austin Texas including
mattresses from helix sleep helix has
built a sleep quiz that takes two
minutes to complete and they use the
answers to match your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress whether you're a side sleeper
hot sleeper cold sleeper you like plush
you like firm with helix there's no more
guessing or confusion just go to helix
sleep calm forward-slash Tim take their
two minutes sleep quiz and they'll match
you to a mattress that will give you the
best sleep of your life that is their
promise for couples helix can even split
the mattress down the middle providing
individual support needs and feel
preferences for each side they have a 10
year warranty and you can test drive
your mattress for 100 nights risk free
right now helix is offering up to 125
dollars off of all mattress orders so
check it out get up to 125 off at helix
sleep comm forward slash Tim that's
helix sleep dot-com forward slash Tim
for 125 dollars off your mattress order
tickle ik helix sleep comm forward slash
Tim
this episode is brought to you by ship
station
if you've ever sold anything online or
if you sell anything online then you
know what a pain in the ass the shipping
process is it's time-consuming it's
expensive
you're always copying and pasting orders
from different sites trying to figure
out the best carrier so on and so forth
it's such a hassle and in previous life
I shipped tens of thousands of units
overseas domestically overnight ground
every possible carrier it drove me
bonkers ship station was created to make
your life easier I wish I had had it
when I was in the biz
so to speak it has the most five-star
reviews of any shipping software four
point nine out of five for Magento users
four point eight out of five for Shopify
users four point five out of five for
big commerce users it goes on and on
whether you're selling on eBay Amazon
Shopify or more than 100 other popular
selling channels shipstation lets you
access all of your orders from one
simple dashboard ship station works with
all of the major shipping carriers
locally and globally including FedEx UPS
and the major local couriers like USPS
ship station will recommend the best
carrier for your needs so that you know
that you're always getting the best deal
they even offer discounts on shipping
costs that are available to say you as a
one-person shop that would normally be
thought of as reserved for large fortune
500 companies so there are a lot of
benefits no other shipping platform
makes shipping faster easier and more
affordable and right now Tim Ferriss
show listeners get to try ship station
free for 60 days when you use promo code
Tim it's risk free you can start your
free trial without even entering your
credit card info just visit ship station
com click on the microphone at the top
of the homepage and type in Tim TI M
that ship station com enter promo code
Tim check it out ship station comm promo
code Tim
why hello boys and girls the ladies and
germs this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
where it is my job to interview
world-class performers experts to tease
out their habits belief systems lessons
learned and so on that you can apply to
your own life my guest today is Neil
deGrasse Tyson I've wanted to have Neil
on this podcast for years who is Neil
astrophysicist Neil deGrasse Tyson on
Twitter at Neil Tyson was appointed the
Frederick P Rose director of the Hayden
Planetarium in 1996 dr. Tyson's
professional research interests are
primarily related to the structure of
the Milky Way galaxy and the formation
of stars supernovas and dwarf galaxies
and you've never heard anyone
communicate and explain quite the way
that Neil does anyway back to the bio
dr. Tyson graduated from Bronx High
School of Science received his BA from
Harvard and earned his PhD in
astrophysics from Columbia University in
1991 in 2001 he was appointed by
President Bush to serve on a 12 member
commission that studied the future of
the u.s. aerospace industry in 2004
Tyson was once again appointed by
President Bush to serve on a nine member
Commission on the implementation of the
United States Space Exploration policy
dubbed the quote moon Mars and beyond
and quote commissioned in 2016 he was
appointed by the US Secretary of Defense
as an advisor to the DoD's future of
scitech innovation DoD is Department of
Defense dr. Tyson has been awarded 21
honorary degrees what that's just crazy
let that sink in for a second okay the
NASA distinguished Public Service Medal
and has authored multiple books on the
universe including space chronicles
facing the ultimate frontier death by
black hole and other cosmic quandary
switch was a New York Times bestseller
and the Pluto files subtitle the rise
and fall of America's favorite planet
chronicling his experience at the center
of the controversy over Pluto's
planetary status his newest book brand
new is letters from an astrophysicist a
companion to his 2017 bestseller
astrophysics for people
in a hurry since 2006 Tyson has appeared
as the on-camera host of PBS Nova's
spin-off program Nova ScienceNOW dr.
Tyson also hosts a popular radio show
and podcast that's a huge understatement
massively popular radio show and podcast
called star talk in addition to the
emmy-nominated star talk TV show and
National Geographic he also hosted a
reboot of Carl Sagan's Cosmos in 2014
without further ado the author of the
new book letters from an astrophysicist
Neil deGrasse Tyson Neil welcome to the
show yeah thanks to him it's my first
time
it is your first time hopefully not your
last but for now the the first debut
appearance of course that's the
department of redundancy department way
to describe it but not our first time
chatting but first time in in this case
being able to ask you all the questions
I'd like to ask and I thought we would
we start talking about talking and
specifically I'd love to hear about any
influences or inspirations for teaching
or speaking you're such a good
communicator and there are many
scientists who are good scientists were
not good communicators there are many
good communicators who are not good
scientists or scientific thinkers who
are some of the people who have
influenced or inspired you when it comes
to communicating the way that you do so
first your credit believe it or not no
one has ever asked me that alright here
we go
promising start this is a good this is a
good good first pitch home run right
there so I can go back to my childhood
and middle school years where I had
already sort of exhausted the exhibitory
of the American Museum of Natural
History's astronomy section which is
basically the Hayden Planetarium and so
it's not just the planetarium their
exhibits and lining the corridors and
things it doesn't take much to exhaust
simple exhibits and fortunately for me
at least the museum had
so it had sort evening classes and and
lectures and lecture series so I was an
avid consumer of these additional
offerings of the institution and I
remembered distinctly there was some
instructors who just had such a facility
with words and sentences and humor and
tenor where I said to myself but let's
just back up I knew I was interested in
the universe from age 9 so this is I'm
already there alright so this is not a
matter of oh they got me and I'm already
there but there was a cup there were a
couple of instructors that had such a
facility with delivering information in
a pleasing enjoyable way that I said to
myself then I must have been 14 or 13
that if I am ever an educator I want to
be as effective as they are and it had
to do with the combination of just you
could just sit down and let the good
storytellers write and that one of them
would be describing sort of the
constellations of the night sky and all
the mythological characters that are up
there and what Greek and Roman
traditions were behind it and what the
stories are and and so to hear how they
told the stories and when and where they
put emphasis I never forgot that and so
so that was one side of it now another
side there was a scientist also an
educator but in this particular case he
had such a facility with the content he
just knew so much about the big bang and
black holes and galaxies and stars and
planets I I said to myself I don't know
if I will ever learn as much as he knows
now I didn't realize you know I was only
14
my life's learning until then you know
my entire life is small compared with
how long he's been alive right I mean he
might have been 50 at the time I don't
know
so but I just could not even imagine
knowing learning what it would take to
learn as much about the universe as he
did but I said if I ever successfully a
scientist on what the command of the
content the way he has and plus he had a
very good sense of humor as well so if
you combine knowledge base humor
facility with words and language and
storytelling that was in me or at least
the mission statement to achieve this
was in me since my mid-teens that's
incredible and directionally he said at
age nine your aura teas are pointed in
terms of interests at the the universe
as you mentioned how did how did that
develop oh so okay so now you are now
the thousands of person to ask I figured
I would follow up with a first by asking
the the nth number question just for
those people who don't know your
background does that negate the first
question no no no I just it doesn't
negate it just averages down it was a
home run you already scored so this is a
bunt let's see if we had it so so it was
a first visit to the Hayden Planetarium
my local planetarium in New York City
which happens to be large and
significant so the word local doesn't
really capture what's going on there
it's a content producing facility so we
produce of course I'm now director of
that planetarium that very same
planetarium but my parents would take my
sister my brother and me to each weekend
it felt like each weekend but was
probably maybe one or two weekends a
month but on family trips to various
cultural institutional offerings in the
city and in the region so didn't matter
it would be we go to the aquarium we'd
go to the zoo we'd go to art the art
museum we'd go to an opera we go to a
play we'd go to a Yankee game you know a
Giants game a college football game a a
is what there would just be something
where we would observe adults doing with
expertise okay so it wasn't just oh you
won't grow up to be a doctor lawyer
Indian chief no it was
what else do full-grown humans do in
this world and that exposure was
significant and I thought it was just
they're just trying to get us out of the
house but there was a master plan in
place a master objective which was to
expose the three of us to as much as
they possibly could so that when we
decided what we wanted to be when we
grew up it would have it would have a
certain authenticity of origin I mean
think of how many people who are raised
by ambitious parents where they the
parents really kind of tell the kids
what they're gonna major you're gonna be
a doctor or you're gonna be a attorney
like your parents like your mother or
you know I never could be an attorney
because that but no you're gonna be one
right there are these pressures some
overt some covert is so many there's so
many places or occasions where kids are
not really doing what their heart wants
them to do they're doing what their
family wants to do what their family
needs them to do
you're gonna inherit my business and
you're gonna you know be an expert and
in furniture you know whatever whatever
it is so that was not going on in our
household in our household it was a free
expression of interest and when I first
went to the Hayden Planetarium at age
nine I was hooked I mean you sit back in
this big comfy chair I realize now that
big comfy chairs that recline in the
dark will put an adult to sleep
immediately that's a kid it was Wow and
then the lights dimmed and the stars
came out at first I thought was a hoax
because I had seen the night sky from
the Bronx where I grew up and you know
you get a couple dozen stars tops and so
I'd had no idea that that wasn't real
that it was light polluted and air
polluted back then was a much more air
pollution
and I had no idea so I froze our hopes
but it was a very it was an entertaining
hoax and so I was not going to stop it
or walk out and only later what I
learned that that sky on the dome was
authentic and and what's embarrassing in
an urban sense is that to this day when
I go to the mountaintop observatory some
of the finest observing sites in the
world and I look up I see the night sky
I wished-for to myself wow this reminds
me of the haydn planets it's a little
embarrassing but it's true and so so
yeah that's that's how it began
meanwhile my brother would we would
visit an art museum and he was totally
taken by art and would ultimately attend
the High School of Music and Art in in
New York and I would ultimately attend
New York's the Bronx High School of
Science so my sister ultimately was a
total sellout and she went into
corporate America she got her MBA so but
she loved horses
and we we've gone horseback riding in
Van Cortlandt Park lehre stables there
and again these are things things you
can do and so she's had a lifelong
appreciation for equine sports and and
just riding in general but my my point
is all of our interests are genuine and
I think we've been happier for it we're
not hiding some inner need at the risk
of disappointing parents so yeah so
that's that's the full story right there
lift that's my origin story and I wanted
to get to the maybe some of the the
inner folds of the the origin story I it
it certainly sounds like you and your
family and you're at your parents
encouragement use New York City as a
learning laboratory of sorts and you had
these weekend excursions you just said
it way better than I just did this
learning laboratory thank you that in
the future yes all yours and
I'd love to hear if anything else comes
to mind say during the week or evenings
when families were together or were
there any other habits or routines or
approaches that they used for
cultivating sure yeah curiosity yes but
before I tell you that there's something
else I want to add and I don't mean to
pit demographic against demographic or
neighborhood against neighborhood but I
can tell you that think about how many
parents particularly back then is less
so today but back in the day of urban
flight where I'm stereotyping here but
let's imagine you just got out of
college you got married
and you got a good job in the city so
you're gonna working in the city and you
and your spouse say let's have kids but
we don't want to raise them in the city
there's no backyard there's no swing set
and so you save your first bonus check
or whatever because these are upwardly
mobile couples and then you buy a home
in the suburbs and that's where you
birth your kids and that's where you
raise them and then they attend suburban
schools so when you go out to the
suburbs there you don't have these
cultural institutions friends it's all
true institutions are focused in the
city not only that on the weekend where
the kids gonna go they go hang out at
the mall right so the interstitial time
the downtime does not have the access
typically no especially not but you know
you don't even know how to drive yet
until you're 16 or 17 so you're already
almost out of high school before you
have a full up sort of driver's license
and so so the fact that we were in the
city meant yes the city was our
laboratory and and this is another quick
thing you didn't ask this but I
remembered researching it you can also
ask the question particularly back in
the very dangerous times of the city
when I grew up there were 2,000
homicides a year in New York City about
seven a day and so that was just your
state of mind this is the 19 late 60s
especially the 1970s that's if you're a
movie buff
that's the decade that escaped from New
York was made you know I think it's got
a cult following but I think was one of
the worst movies ever made not not just
because I'm from New York City and the
government had turned Manhattan into a
prison right the the island is a prison
right so they just dumped criminals
there and let him fend for themselves
so wholly aside they did that to my
hometown I still think it was an awful
movie but any yes that was made in that
era so now I wanted to slip in another
little fact that you can ask the
question what are the chances given
crime and all the other factors of not
surviving to age 18 okay and you can say
I want to live where my chances of
survival to 18 are at its highest that
would be one measure of the safety of
the neighborhood that you choose well
someone did a study on that and here's
what they found they said let's compare
the city and the suburbs the cities
where everyone is thinking that
everything is dangerous right so going
back this study was done probably about
when the homicide rate was around a
thousand a year it had dropped I think I
remember reading this in the 1980s
oh by the way right now it's just a few
hundred those most of those homicides
are between people who know each other
which is very hard for the police to
stop if you have access to each other so
it's between you and your drug dealer
you know that sort of thing right and
and so if you're pretty sure no one you
know wants to kill you the statistics
are extraordinary least safe for the New
York City today today but we're going
back 30 years so now watch so the study
was what are the chances of dying before
age 18 and in the city oh and you want
to compare neighborhoods of equal income
okay so you go to the Upper East Side of
New York a very well-to-do place and
then you go to Scarsdale a well-to-do or
Greenwich a well-to-do suburb of New
York
and one is in in Westchester one is in
Connecticut but they're both in
commuting distance of New York
here's what they found that you were two
or three times less likely to survive
age 18 in the suburbs than you were in
the city at any income level and you say
well what's going on there well I
thought the city was dangerous the city
is dangerous but you know it's more
dangerous driving
okay well driving is more dangerous so
auto accidents of drunken teens are who
just got there you know they're
learner's permit or they're just fresh
off than just minted driver's license or
at prom night or you kill somebody else
because you're drunk or you were playing
in your front yard and the ball rolled
into the street and you're a kid and you
roll out and you get hit by a car car
related deaths vast so they swamped the
the the deaths from violence that would
occur in the city also suicides were
higher in the suburbs then in the city
and I wonder not that I have any
expertise in psychological health but
you got to wonder how low can you feel
walking home after you've stepped over
three homeless people right I mean what
how how much at the bottom are you it's
as red Fox once joked because poor
people commit suicide at a lower rate
that higher then rich people he said
well it's hard to kill yourself jumping
out of the basement and those red fox
anyhow that's just a little side thing
about city life versus suburban life and
as you may know there's a there's a
flight back to the city in recent years
upwardly mobile people want to end their
did well in college and their their
lifelong learners they want to stay
close to the learning centers and you
have art openings and wine tastings and
an indie movie premieres and none of
that's in the suburbs that's the that's
the challenge here so there's a there's
a return back to the cities in the real
estate trends in the recent years but
anyhow getting back to your point so
once any of our interest who were
revealed my brother my sister and my
interest were manifested then my parents
fed those interests so my parents are a
sociologist active in the civil rights
movement the 1960s even worked under
Mayor Lindsay
um back then just trying to keep the
powder keg
you know from igniting and in fact in
the late 60s New York City had only the
smallest of inner city unrest relative
to watts or Detroit or Cincinnati or
Washington or Atlanta there were cities
that burned especially in 1968 the the
the most turbulent year of the most
turbulent decade in American history
since the Civil War the 1860s so there
was New York City and my father was
active in that he was commissioner of
the human resources administration and
what is that these are people who care
about you and what job you might have
and what is a riot but the last gasp of
hopelessness expressed that's what a
riot is and if you have hope we're gonna
have a job this summer I'm gonna make
money I'm gonna do this they're people
who care about me the city cares this
whole state of mind has basically I will
come out and just say diffused whatever
might have been a riot in the biggest
city in the country with the largest
quote ghetto in the country back now we
just call them inner cities so so that's
what my father was engaged in and my
mother was a homemaker until we became
empty nest and then she went back to
school and went on and got a got her
undergraduate degree which she hadn't
finished before we got married and then
a graduate degree in gerontology so I'm
taking her down that path just to alert
you that both my parents were active in
professionally relieving the suffering
of others
right that's their goal and here's their
kid the astrophysicist so I have no clue
how to help me along at all except
whenever my mother would visit a
bookstore she would go to the remainder
table I don't know if those still exist
you know where publishers they printed
too many books and then they just want
to get rid of them they shake the tree
the books fall out and they sell high
quality books for like 50 cents or a
dollar and my mother just find an e-book
on mathematics or science certainly
astronomy Botham for a low low budget
and they would come home they would be
my birthday gifts I had the biggest
library of any middle schooler in the
hood and that included brainteaser books
so they didn't know for sure and but
basically um you know they were
something some of this islets how does
the saying go raise the flag and see
what salutes it right [ __ ] so they they
were raising these book flags and which
ones that I did attract me which ones
didn't most of them were good most of
them further developed me they would buy
art books for my brother and so it would
say it's seeing what our interests are
and then supporting it and that's I had
no no regrets and that was my wife's and
my objectors without kids my wife has a
PhD in mathematical physics and I'm a
PhD in astrophysics and people come up
to and say are you or your kids okay can
that mess up your kids it's not people
only think that when you have science
parents not when they have lawyer
parents or anything but so our kids are
into their own thing they're not
pressured to do science or anything like
that I have to I have to pause just to
mention that this is deja vu all over
again for me it's the first time I've
had a guest describe exactly what
happened with my family also my parents
exposed this to a lot they would see
what caught our attention and they
didn't have budget for new bikes or
other things but my mom would always say
we have budget
for books and what that meant was going
to the remainder table specifically and
the bookstore to pick up books on
whatever had caught our attention it's
very very similar that's really Wyatt
and and the thing is so I as I got older
when I considered writing books myself I
said suppose my book ends up on the
remainder technically it's a bittersweet
thing it's like I don't want it to be on
the remainder table but that's how I cut
my teeth in this so it's not selling
well if it's another remainder table
actually that's not always true
sometimes they just want it the the
hardcover is slowing down and they want
to go to paperback so then they release
the hardcover to the remainder table and
then the paperback does well in another
and on another budget level but so yeah
the remain a table I have a love-hate
relationship now that I'm an author if
we jump from where we started around 14
at the beginning this conversation and
flash-forward not not too far forward I
suppose could you describe and this is
I'm sure something you've been asked
before but I'm gonna add a twist to it
which is could you describe for people
who don't know the name who Carl Sagan
is and then also perhaps share a story
or any observations about what people
don't fully appreciate about him or
don't know about him yeah excellent
thanks for that question so Carl Sagan
is probably the most famous popularizer
of science there ever was and I can't
say is the most popular scientist that
would probably be Albert Einstein or
Isaac Newton or or Stephen Hawking but
he if you look at sort of visibility was
a pretty very productive scientist in
his own right but that's not how most
people remember him they must they
remember him as
initially author of some very very
readable books on the universe as as
multi-time guest on The Tonight Show
with Johnny Carson Johnny Carson the The
Tonight Show host who preceded Jay Leno
who preceded Jimmy Fallon
so the only been a handful of hosts of
The Tonight Show Carl Sagan came of age
at a time when Johnny Carson was host
and Johnny Carson was a big fan of
science and more so than Jay Leno was so
Jay Leno in all of his tenure had very
few scientists on I was on his show like
the last week before he swapped out with
with Jimmy Fallon
so I am so Carl Sagan had a very potent
way of communicating science concepts
and he I was already knew I was going to
do astrophysics before I even knew he
existed so I can't credit him for for
inspiration to become an astrophysicist
but what I can credit for me what I can
credit him for is is the power of
analogy and I'll give you an example I
heard him give a talk and he was
describing the size of a of a payload in
a space mission so rather than say it
was you know 8 inches by 6 inches but he
didn't say that he said it's about the
size of a two pound coffee hand I know
exactly what that is okay I got that all
right and something that's simple not
giving the metric of something giving
something else that is familiar in your
life somehow makes it real so that every
sense fourth any time I saw two pound of
coffee can
I thought about space missions right so
he was he was really good at that
and so I said wow okay if I'm ever in
the position of communicating complex
ideas to the public I won't try to make
sure that I can fold this in as well and
I think my my my
one of my best versions of this was I
was being interviewed on The Today Show
back when when the Cassini spacecraft
had just pulled into orbit around
Jupiter
excuse me around Saturn for twelve-year
observing mission right observing the
Rings ring system the moons their
magnetic fields the gas everything about
the Saturnian system and and the host
asked me you know trying to go
hard-hitting said well dr. Tyson this is
after we said nice things about that
spacecraft now it was gonna take a turn
now I knew journalists do this so I was
just ready he had no idea how ready I
was now comes the question there's a
doctor there's a three billion dollar
mission how can we possibly justify that
expense with all the problems we have in
the world today okay if I'm gonna be
stumped on national television it's not
gonna be by a morning it's gonna have to
be someone who was like in the trenches
in Vietnam
one of those reporters all right then
I'm okay I'm at least them on the
Morning News I'm sorry
so I said wait it's not three billion
dollars it's the cost of the twelve
years it's what matters is the budget
per year all right and so the budget per
year you know it's three or four hundred
million dollars a year and Americans
spend more than that per year on lip
balm we all you know it lip on it is in
a general sense so it includes lipstick
chapstick you know all the stuff we put
on I'll let you add that up it cost more
than that mission and so I was very
proud of that I didn't know at the time
that this is the Today Show and you know
have the people in the plaza outside
looking in the window holding up signs
from their hometown I didn't know that
the audio from the show gets piped out
into the street because when the show
ended I walked out there was a chorus of
people people holding up their chapstick
saying we want to go to Saturn I could
start a chapstick movement but all that
it's traceable to Carl Sagan's ability
to find some other analogy that drives
home the scientific point that he was
making so to complete the influencers on
me as a as an educator that that his
facility with that I tried to make part
of my own tactics methods tools and
tactics when I find myself in those
situations and in the in the mid 70s Wow
excuse me and after after everything I
just said he went on and made cosmos
okay and it's called a personal voyage
and came out in 1980 aired on PBS and
that was seen I think by a billion
people it was the most successful
documentary there ever was and that
really made him a household name at the
time we're now 40 years ago and you know
invited by heads of state to places and
this sort of thing and what
distinguished that from any other
documentary you know no one thinks of
cosmos as a documentary but there's
something else going on in it and it has
to do with the creativity of not only
Carl but especially the the co-writer
that had two car riders at the time and
Riaan who he would later marry and Steve
sodor who is a colleague of mine in fact
he's got an office in my department they
have that combination of wit insight
sensitivity to the human condition made
cosmos something else it was like this
is not just about the universe it's
about why all of science matters to us
not only to you the individual but to
civilization and it was a call to - it
was a it was a call to action to become
better shepherds of this world back then
we were still in the Cold War so nuclear
threat was real I was privileged enough
to host the second of these cosmoses if
that's the plural of cosmos a cosmos is
in 2014
34 years after the first and Andrian as
the lead writer in that she while not a
scientist herself I can tell you that
she's one of the most enlightened people
I've ever met she's she she sees and
feels the science so that there's
science that needs to be conveyed she
will find a way to communicate that
science so that you will never forget it
that becomes part of your inner soul of
concern and curiosity and that's the
potency of this series so so I don't
think science communication and science
education has ever been the same since
cosmos has landed on the landscape so
I'm gonna come up or I should say come
up come back to a Carl Sagan follow-up
but since we're talking about science
science communication I would like to
revisit and feel free to fact-check this
cuz I I don't want to believe everything
I find on the internet but this is this
is from a Harvard Business Review and
the question to you was how can schools
and workplaces emphasize curiosity we
can focus on the schools and the the
answer I have which which I'd love to
hear you comment on is there should be a
class where you learn how and why
science works and what the methods and
tools of science do in many people's
understanding science is just this body
of knowledge but really it's a way of
querying nature
how would you teach such a class if you
have if you had that as your a mandate
and where you chose that as your mission
what might the structure or curriculum
look like if you were to teach such a
class okay first I have no memory I
don't being in the Harvard Business
Review yeah Wow okay who'd have been
could have been syndicated could have
been copied and pasted who those what
agreement they have right because why
would like Harvard Business really care
about me at all so yes but that entire
quote is accurate it's what I think and
it's what I've said and I would I would
double down on that and say this
shouldn't just be one class this should
be an entire line of curricula that
threads through all of your years in
school that capture that the need to
stimulate curiosity so yeah you have to
learn how to ask a questions and a
course is typically are here here is
knowledge and learn it rather than here
is something we don't understand how
would you probe it how would you ask
what what puts sequence of questions
would you ask to to learn what this
thing is right and I mean let me just
this is might be contrived but it'll
serve the point let's say there's a
sapling there like a like a small tree
it's growing you say if you never knew
if you didn't know anything about this
what how would you go about
investigating it you'd say well okay I'd
ask you know what is it weigh can I
weigh it what what are these things on a
thing or there we call them leaves or
what's the purpose of a leaf what
happens if I block it from sunlight
because it looks like it wants to see
sunlight what happens if I do that what
happens if I what does it need to live
does it need soil does it need water
like it likes water what happens if I
don't give it water what happens if I
give it coca-cola or something so so
it's an open-ended inquiry into the
operations of nature and the open
endedness I think I think is what
stimulates curiosity because some of
your questions won't lead to an answer
and others will so you know you want to
hone that you don't always know in
advance which are the best questions to
ask if you ask the question what kind of
cheese is the moon made out of okay well
okay you know grammatically that's a
legitimate question but scientifically
you know if you don't know and you think
it's cheese then you'll set up
experiments to try to test is it
Rocafort is it be dumb is it goat cheese
you know or do you know and you find out
that none of anything productive why
because it's not made of cheese that
itself is a revelation
it's made of silicates you know silicon
is an active ingredient in rocks so and
silica is a very common ingredient in
the universe so so I think the class
would stimulate open-ended inquiry in
all the different academic subjects so
not only the science subjects but also
history and English I mean why not you
know
where did this word come from I don't
know let's find out well here's the
route here's the this oh who first used
it you know why is it that I did not
know about the Oxford English Dictionary
until I was like 25 or 30 okay how why
why is that so you know the Oxfordian
area is every single appearance of a
word in the history of the language with
the usage of the word pivoted so it has
not only the first appearance of the
word but any subsequent appearance with
where someone gave it a different nuance
of meaning and that's kind of fun to dig
that up how come we never did that in
English class
that would have been really fun and I
would have learned then instead of two
years ago
that the word acronym acronym we all
know this word do you realize that's a
modern word I have a dictionary from
1939 and it's not in that dictionary
it's an unabridged dictionary it's not
in that dictionary
I would later learn that that word was
invented to describe all of the
abbreviations that came out of agencies
and organizations in the Second World
War
acronym and technically it's an
abbreviation that you can pronounce as a
word so NASA is an acronym and scuba is
an acronym and laser is an acronym but
IBM or CIA are not acronyms because you
can't spell them out but that would have
been just kind of cool
this is inquiry this is free inquiry
into knowledge and if you can stimulate
that then kids who get out of school
will not celebrate the end of school
they will lament that they will omit
what I can't learn anymore well yes you
can because you've now know how to be
curious and you will now shape a life
long you now create an arc of learning
that continues for the rest of your life
hmm this is a really important subject
of course and thank you very long
answers is that okay
long answers are great this is okay this
is why we have time so that's not a
short podcast no not not only allowed
but encouraged all right and I'd like to
dig a little deeper on scientist versus
scientific thinking because it strikes
me that I've come across many people
just in travels public speaking and so
on different types of engagements who
would say i'm not a scientist and in
saying that sort of throw out the hope
or possibility of developing scientific
thinking and I wouldn't call myself a
scientist but I've greatly benefited
from reading Bertrand Russell or there's
a book called bad science by Ben
Goldacre who's a
an MD but who writes about many
different things and this book talks
about how to read a study and how to
read journalism that supposedly
accurately covers studies I found it
deeply enriching and valuable in
navigating reality are there any
particular books or resources you would
recommend or approaches for people who
would like to develop their ability to
look at the world through this type of
lens that you're describing so that's an
important and insightful question
because you know you should really be a
the host of a podcast if I haven't
convinced you of that by the end of this
you know so you're right not everyone
can be a scientist and there's all this
talk we need more scientists in Congress
and and I think that'd be great
but what you really need are
scientifically literate leaders who know
how to trust the emergent scientific
truths of scientific research and how to
then embrace that and fold it in as
necessary into legislation or policy
either at the executive branch or the
legislative branch so so it's possible
to be scientifically literate and not be
an expert in any particular scientific
line discipline and so what does it mean
tapping back to a few moments ago it
means knowing how to ask questions it
means knowing how to invoke scepticism
scepticism allows an open mind for
things that you're unfamiliar with to be
true but it does not allow your mind to
be so open that your brains spill out
and you lose the capacity to judge what
is true and what is not and so I in this
in this effort to know what is true and
what is not I at the risk of sounding
self-serving one of my books
it's called
death by black hole in spite of its
title is actually its glory title it's
actually about what science is and how
and why it works and when people write
to me with questions I know based on how
they worded the question whether they
read that book or not that's how
effective I think it can be on the
reader because it says their chapters in
there on how do we know what we know and
why do we know what we know and what is
our confidence in what we know and and
so there's an entire unpacking of the
anatomy of science in that book and
until recently that was my biggest
selling book but I a couple of books
that have done better than that since
then but it's I'm very proud of that
book in in the summation of what it
delivers to the reader if you're
collecting book names another good book
is how to lie with statistics a cute
little tiny book that tells you all the
things who people want to fool you into
thinking something that's true that's
not and how they manipulate statistics
in order to accomplish this it's its
imprint and it's been in print for like
50 years I think it came out in the
1950s so that would make it 60 years so
that I think put that one very high on
the list and I'm going to make a note of
this other book that you're describing
what was it bad science that if it
influenced you as much as you say then
that I'm going to check it out it's it's
it's a good book it's by Ben Goldacre
Gould and an acre like the parcel of
land and it's it's very helpful
specifically for parsing health-related
information in media or marketing and
yes so one thing I have to say is the
press in in all fairness to them they
want to you know each journalist wants
to be the first to break a story and
because then they everyone references
them
as the and you know this is how Pulitzer
Prizes are given if you break a story
and if you hang out at the coffee
lounges of scientific conferences and
you hear a new result that could be
amazing or devastating or mind-blowing
and you write an article about it what
you're not doing as a journalist is
honestly presenting the the likelihood
that it's true you're just presenting it
as true or you'll say if this is true
this will revolutionize everything and
then you leave that phrase and the in
the first sentence of the article and
all the rest of the article assumes it's
true and so the reader is left with the
assumption that it's true whereas a
scientific truth is never any one
person's research paper ever ever the
research frontier is a ratty bloody
bleeding place and it's most things will
be wrong and the few things that are
right are demonstrated to be right
because of verified other research that
supports it and so what you're looking
for is a consensus not of opinion I'm
using that word cause I don't have a
better word it's a consensus of
scientific experiments and observations
and and once you have that you can say
oh my gosh this result continues to
persist as the results of experiments
even went conducted by this person's
competitor even when conducted in
another country where they use 240 volts
instead of 120 volts you know maybe the
the power of the experiment influences
the results you know who knows you just
don't know so when you have enough
different people getting the same result
now the journalist can talk about it as
the new truth but they don't yeah the
importance of replication I think does
not get enough popular press and you
mentioned earlier that
in in in in some measure becoming a
scientifically literate person is
determining what sequence of questions
you might ask to figure something out
and I think you'll I think you could
enjoy Ben's work then I can probably can
point into some of it because it'll
it'll help readers to at the very least
look at say a a piece in a newspaper or
a magazine or online and identify what
is missing right so if somebody says
eating bananas doubles the risk of
colorectal cancer something like that
right well they're a bunch of questions
which is like how did you determine that
how many bananas were you injecting
bananas into rats are rats comparable to
humans and if if doubled means that the
risk went from you know one in 20
million to two and 20 million is it
really something that you need to worry
about and right because we remember that
were doubled without reference to the
baseline on which you would write like
that how do I with statistics is a great
one - yeah make sure your y-axis has a
as as a label the the I promised I would
come back to it and I want to in part
because Carl Sagan is one of those
people ie I would have loved to have met
I would have loved to have had a chance
to meet him if this is true why did the
admissions office of Cornell University
forward your application to Karl's
attention oh yeah so when I was 17 a
senior in high school applying to
college I Cornell where Carl Sagan was
professor was one of the schools I
applied to and unknown to me they
forwarded my application to him they had
already accepted me and they they I
think they had already accepted me is
that right actually it doesn't matter at
this point they afforded to him to get
his reaction to it and my application
was dripping with the universe I was in
the astronomy club I
walk dogs to buy my own telescope that
in the glory days of dog walking before
you had to clean up after three
portraits Cooper laws and I he saw my
application and sent me a letter in the
mail saying I saw your application I'd
love to help you decide if you want to
come to Cornell and I'd be delighted to
meet with you and give you tour of the
campus and the next time you're up here
was like holy [ __ ] this is Carl Sagan
the one who was on The Tonight Show and
it's all the books yes it was and sure
enough I got on a bus and went from New
York City to Ithaca all four and a half
or five hours of that bus ride and sure
enough he met me out front of the lab
and in fact it was a Saturday that he
did this because I couldn't take time
off from school and showed me the lab
and I remembered he was sitting behind
his desk and he reached back didn't even
look grab the book from the shelf and
then signed it was just one of his books
that he wrote that's badass if you have
a look there's one of the books that you
wrote so I still have that book is
signed to Neal future astronomer amazing
that was the it's still in there and so
I Oh then then it started snowing and I
was scheduled to take the bus back and
he left me his his home phone number and
said if the bus can't get through then
call me and spend the night with my
family and go out tomorrow and I thought
who what what is what's going on why I'm
thinking to myself and I realized that
he was deeply committed to making sure
that a next generation had access the
next generation had the enthusiasm that
he had and I said to myself at the time
if I am ever as remotely famous as he is
then I will give time
two students allocate time to students
the way he has to me and now I joke that
because now of course I have my own
books behind my desk but I think for
what's to come in every time I do they
say yep this is a homage to Carl
and and I joked that you know if I'm on
the phone you know Barack I gotta get
back to you I got a student who's
waiting for students first so I already
knew I was going to be an astrophysicist
at that point but heat that exchange
with him codified for me what kind of a
scientist I would be what kind of
humanity I would carry with me in my
interactions with others especially
students what do you hope to instill or
infuse in in students if you have a
short amount of time with them if they
are in your office and you're going to
reach back and grab a book well yeah a
great question it's ambition it's you
know ambitions gotten a bad bad meaning
lately because people think oh that's an
ambitious person in the in the office
place you know and in the in the in the
business setting that usually means
you're stepping on top of people to get
forward you know that's an ambitious
person and it doesn't always mean that
but it carries some of that patina today
I'm simply saying how what is your
confidence in yourself what are you
doing to boost who and what you are in
this subject and how far do you want to
take it these are all aspects of the
ambition tree and so I also encourage
people you should not distract yourself
with what grade you're getting after
your second job no one asks you what
grade you got ever all right they go ask
any thirty year old person when's the
last time someone asks what their GPA
was they won't even remember when that
was what matters is are you good problem
solver are you moral don't you
hard-worker - are you a good leader are
you
you have insights into the field are you
these are the questions that matter and
if you take hard classes rather than
easy classes you might get a lower grade
sure but if you take an easy class and
get a high grade well that's what
everyone else is getting so you will not
distinguish yourself in the actual
workplace because everyone else has
exactly that same profile because they
took all the same easy class as you did
if you take a harder class risk the
lower grade you are actually ascending a
pyramid or a ladder let's say that
you're adding rungs to a ladder that you
then ascend and every next rung you are
higher above the ground that everybody
else and at one point you will get you
will reach a rung of the ladder where no
one else is adjacent to you and people
have to beat a path to your door to
solve their problems their business
problems their academic whatever it is
they're doing because you kept ascending
doing the hard things to accomplish it
and this is this is a recurring message
that I give students who come in and in
in my my next book the letters from an
astrophysicist it's curious that you
have these arc of questions because
these are letters I've written in
exchange two questions asked of me where
all of these topics have been covered
and it's because I get letters from
students oh they're all so letters
there's an open letter I open letter to
my parents that I wrote for the 30th
wedding anniversary this is back in the
1980s where I'm thanking them for being
supporting me you know so this whole
part of this conversation that involved
me remembering what my parents and
that's in there you'll see that and
wisdom from my father about you know
what how to stay grounded but also
continue to to
it could continue to dream about where I
want to land however high above the
ground that dream is so so I'm delighted
to say that a lot of this conversation
is actually contained in that book now
let's talk about that for a second so
the letters from an astrophysicist you
have in reading in preparation for this
looking at your bio looking at your
current projects I I somehow create the
illusion that I do a lot of stuff but
you really seem to have an incredible
ability to work on multiple projects you
certainly have more opportunities then
bandwidth to to execute on all of those
opportunities
how how do you choose to write a book
let's say like letters from an
astrophysicist like why why that book
and why now just the decision process
for choosing that amongst all of the
many things that you could spend time on
yes so it's a matter of you remember the
game and they arcade where all these
coins are are piled on top of each other
and you have this pushing bar yes and
the bar pushes and you add another coin
and it pushes and there's a big stack is
it going to come no it's not gonna come
let me try it so so I don't know what
that game is called but I think we're
all familiar with it there there are
occasions where so many things are
pre-loaded in my life then I have to ask
well what am I going to do today instead
of tomorrow what should I have done
yesterday well there's this big stack
that's ready to spill over that's the
one I got to do now otherwise I'll lose
it all a little roll down the street so
some of it is is that not to overstretch
the metaphors but some of it is like the
person who spins the plates and keeps
them all spinning all at once I don't
know if that that arcade trick is still
you know that doesn't make the evening
variety shows anymore know that used to
count as entertaining
plates spinning on sticks but yeah so
I'm spinning and people have asked well
how do you achieve equilibrium in life
but what is the balance there is no
balance it is never in balance ever with
family with kids with wife with work
with writing with with television and
other media with Twitter
nothing is ever in balance and so I
spend a lot of time trying to do what I
do do more efficiently today than
yesterday and then you can squeeze in a
little more but no there is no balance
there isn't no how do I accomplish it I
don't know it's now the letters book
although has a has a simpler origin
story so I've been answering letters
from the public forever in fact my first
and third books are compliation zuv QA
that I used to have a QA column in a
magazine called stardate and there was
under pen name Merlin so my very first
book ever is called Merlin's tour of the
universe which was a compilation of
those letters and then I had more and it
had enough for a second volume which
became my third book but that was 40
years ago 30 years ago right now in sort
of my modern life I would answer
questions from the public and every now
and then but some of the questions would
be sort of straightforward science
questions and I have a team of people at
the Hayden Planetarium who can field
those so and I make sure that they who
was answered under their own name if
they answered it even though it came to
me it would come from them other letters
much more personal much more specific to
me about in reaction to something I said
or wrote or or or those letters I would
answer personally and one out of 10 of
those letters I would find myself doing
a little extra homework to make sure I
gave this sort of the fleshy
to answer I could or I would put in a
little extra literary effort and when I
would do that I say you know it'd be a
shame if only this one person saw this
letter so I put it aside in a folder on
the possibility that I would one day
collect letters into a volume and so two
years ago because you know books take
time to plan and contract and all of
this I said wow I've got 500 letters of
this variety where I've put an extra
effort to communicate and I think it's
time for a book so I called them down to
about 200 and that was still a lot and
with the help of my agent editor said
let's hone it down some more so now the
actual book letters from an
astrophysicist has a hundred and one
letters which is the creme de la creme
de la creme with regard to range of
content with regard to insights with
regard to to plight of the person who
asks the questions I've three of them
are from prison inmates others are from
parents trying to be better at raising
their kids there's a whole chunk from
religious people there's a Muslim Jews
Buddhists but most of the religions as
you might guess are from Christians who
are who are desperately trying to
reconcile science with biblical passages
and so there's quite the slice of who is
out there and who is asking questions of
an astrophysicist and so that that
became the collection so the editing was
huge because you can't put everybody's
full letter in because many of them are
just rambling BAM bleah and so I
paraphrase many of the layers just to
get it just to get it in there and but
once that was done and then you have to
sort of edit for clarity and grammar and
all the rest of this oh what an
editorial choice I said when punctuation
is
is expressing emotion when excessive
punctuation expresses emotion I leave it
in so someone when someone says I want
to know the answer to this now and like
now is capitalized has three exclamation
points I leave it in just so you can
share the person's feelings in composing
the letter one of the chapters is hate
mail just really pissed off people so
I'm just honest about how what kind of
Correspondence I've had with people most
of it was over a 10-year period when my
email was publicly findable on the
internet and some other letters have
trickled in since then the prison
letters have trickled in since then they
don't have internet so it comes as a
paper letter to my office and so so yeah
and so that so that we've been working
on that for the last two years and so
finally it hits October yeah exciting
congratulations
I want to come back to the comment on
balance which which makes sense to me it
may be like trying to stabilize your
heart rate indefinitely it's not a great
idea analogy yeah heart rate variability
it's a thing and in navigating a full
life as you do if and when you ever feel
say overwhelmed or scattered in some way
or if you feel like you've lost your
focus temporarily what do you do do you
have any practices or questions anything
that that you use to refocus or sort of
down-regulate in order to to reassess
things uh that's a great question and I
think that would be a perfect question
for most people but I'm run my life a
little differently from that and so it's
as follows I agree to probably ten
percent more projects then I will finish
I get about four times as many requests
to participate in projects then I will
ever that's not to say no to most things
and the ones I say yes to it's about 110
percent so it's like airline overbooking
if you continue being creative analogy
yeah it's it's you don't over booked so
much that you know those a mutiny or
that there's there's a people want to
overthrow your but there's just enough
so that circumstances will have whatever
is the hundred percent of what I produce
get made the other ten percent don't get
me it's that simple
and so basically I default on about ten
percent of the projects that I agree to
in advance and that means the time is
always completely full always and how do
I refocus no it's not quite like that my
day as is true with anybody's day is
comprised of time slots of very
different quality from one another
alright when I'm on the subway I sit in
the corner with a hat and glasses so I
minimize how the selfies that would get
requested and I do email email is you
know you can do email any time of day or
night you don't have to I have to focus
now I'm about to do email no you can do
email waiting for the bus alright so the
interstitial time in my day I do email
it's not the only time I do email but
that's when I do a lot of the tedious
email when I wouldn't otherwise be doing
anything okay my wife is an avid
consumer of news she sends me clips
mostly from the New York Times but other
sources as well if she thinks it has
some relevance to me remember she has a
PhD in mathematical physics so we have
strong alignment in terms of what what I
would consume and find interesting she's
not sending you a lot
horoscopes haha no so so she actually is
a is a is a filter pre-filter for news
right and so that that works great there
are periods of time on the weekends
where I have a five-hour block I will
write during five hour blocks it might
take you an hour to get into it all
right well if you only have an hour
block and it takes you an hour to get
into it you can't write an hour blocks
that doesn't make any sense
so I all of the timeframes throughout
the week are allocated for what kind of
things I would do in them so there isn't
a time while I have to focus
well I only have an hour I don't have to
focus I'm just doing email it's not
about getting ready to focus or
regrouping or plus everything I agreed
to I'm excited about I want to do it I
do it because I think I can do it
uniquely and so there isn't this are I
got a slog through this I'm fortunate
that most of what occupies my day is
electively as electively landed on my
calendar lights a patient does I'm not a
medical doctor yeah I don't feel like
open-heart surgery tonight no I don't
write they don't have this luxury they
have to be on on point on focus when
that is necessary so I I all I do is
study the universe the patient never
dies let's talk about dr. Tyson
Airlines for a second yeah with the
overbooking so in in the airline
business they have systems for managing
overbooking if everyone happens to show
up so they might ask for volunteers and
then they offer bribes and then they
offer free trips and then so on and so
forth what is your approach to canceling
or renegotiating the 10% breakage so to
speak that overage what what is the what
does the communication look like yeah so
it's you know there's a lot of finesse
there again
that's another insightful question
because the energy and effort to say no
gracefully is way greater than saying
yes absolutely
because you can say yes ungracefully and
it say yes but a no there's no reason to
make enemies with people you want to
make sure they're still there you want
to make sure they might ask you once
again to do what it might be and they
maybe it'll end up in the hundred
percent rather than in the in the
overbooking part so just just to be
clear the overbooked could have been in
the in the fully in the in the
accommodative part it just landed in the
overbooked section so what I what I will
typically do I'll send a a polite note
over grant and say my calendar got away
from me I could not keep up and that is
a very believable fact right they know
what I'm doing and how productive I am
and then I'll try to offer something in
recompense I will say can you check back
with me in the spring and when I think I
might able will be more cleared than it
is now
or I there are places where people want
me to come give a talk or to host a
fundraiser or something and I said say
maybe I can do it I'm not sure I'll know
I can't do it but how about this I will
donate autographed books for you to
auction at this fundraiser and then
there's some come back so that's my
equivalent of you know offering discount
on another trip or whatever airlines are
doing these days got it thank you
yeah this is this is sort of an area of
study that's become increasingly
interesting to me not not just how to
say no initially which may be the
easiest if done well the first no but
also how to how to renegotiate as needed
when circumstances change or when you're
overbooked and things along those lines
so thanks for sharing your approach I've
been fascinated by your
approach to preparation in a number of
different examples that came up when I
was reading in prep for this that the
first was despite being wooed by by Carl
Sagan you did you did not go to Cornell
you were accepted at Harvard NYU MIT and
Cornell maybe among others but I and
I'll just give two examples that I want
to follow up for the questions so these
are both from The New Yorker profile but
you you went about decided to go by
making by the way yeah that that New
Yorker profile I was gonna write a
companion to that because the while the
profile was fact-checked it was not
impression checked okay and and you can
say something that is factually true but
that you can ask if someone reads this
what are they going to think yes and if
they don't think what that which is true
even though what they read was
technically a fact yeah then the article
is not authentically communicating
reality and so I was gonna do that and I
just never got around to it because it
was we kind of nitpicky and let me just
move on I might still do it if I ever
teach a writing class which I once did
by the way I was a visiting a I was a
visiting writing professor at Yeshiva
College in ok in Upper Manhattan of
fascinating a visiting professor of
writing and I talked it was of course a
nonfiction writing and science writing
and so I very much enjoyed that it
allowed me to formulate what it is I do
in the context of a curriculum rather
than just this is what I do so right so
I was going to do that but so now you
can if you're gonna quote from it if
there's an impression check I will jump
in oh yes please do and and and I'm
sorry that you had that experience I
also had that experience with a New
Yorker profile which was really
upsetting to me at the time with the the
impression
sort of the impression assessment as you
put it which I think I put very well so
these I think may be pretty neutral so
the the two things that I wanted to
mention and you can correct me if these
are inaccurate where to decide where to
go
undergrad you created a spreadsheet that
listed recent contributors physics and
astrophysics articles to Scientific
American showing which schools they de
tended in which faculty they had later
joined the school that appeared most
frequently on spreadsheet was Harvard
and so you decide to go there and then
I'll give you one more and then you
could correct or that's accurate
okay great because ii was before going
on the daily show this is with jon
stewart you studied past episodes
counting how many sentences john would
permit a guest to speak before butting
in with a joke and so you were able to
really not necessarily script out but
but planned very effectively having
taken those preparatory steps and what
what I'd love to know is if there's if
there's a particular example that comes
to mind of preparation really really
paying off if there were any inflection
points in your life or just particularly
important moments where preparation has
paid off for you you know it paid off in
a not in a literal money sense but in a
in a success sense it pays off every
single time I am interviewed on
television because I studied look at the
at the host and I look at like I said as
was accurately portrayed in that profile
for John Stewart I knew that if he
interrupts you before you get a point
across everyone will laugh at his
comedic quip but now you have this
dangling information that you have to
get back to and maybe you won't get back
to it smoothly and maybe the
conversation will move on and that makes
for a messy trail in the exchange that
you're having with the host so I would
parcel my information in these container
ships in these containers where I would
get that across
he then interrupts and now we have a
full fully expressed thought and we have
a funny quip and then we move on and now
we have a nicely knitted together
interview so it pays off every single
time I study well how often do they
reference current events well I better
do my three-day read of current events
so that if they're not gonna go back a
week because it's not going to be
current in people's minds they'll go
back three days tops typically one or
two days in a reference and so I will
have to study that I also need to know
depending how pop culture eyes the
person is I'll go in there brushing up
on what did Beyonce do what did you know
you pick some pop performers do they do
anything funny or stupid or embarrassing
I need to know that because they might
make reference to it and I don't want us
to look you know look like I'm not
connected as a result I spend some
stupid amount of time that's not fair I
spend more time than I otherwise would
how's that for saying it politely expose
myself to pop culture and current events
we all should of course but pop culture
getting exposure to pop culture is what
enables me to communicate with people
who live in pop culture be they
interviewers or their audience you know
what I'd love to do is I only have a
handful of questions left is for those
people who listen to this interview or
any interview on on this podcast it's
it's sometimes easy to feel intimidated
by guests when reading or hearing about
the many many many great successes if
you'd be open to it just to humanize
things but would you be open to sharing
how a failure or apparent failure
perhaps set you up for later success or
a tough time that you were able to get
through are you are you open to sharing
what's of course well so first of all
let's start
with the more recent example there was
an episode of The Colbert Report I ended
up being on his show about 13 14 times
something like I think I was his most
repeated guest actually one of the times
I missed a current event now eat his
interview in character is the most
challenging interview I do ever I've
ever done on television and to this day
is the most challenging because Stephen
Colbert is smart I think he's the
smartest one out there and he's creating
this character so I have to know what
there's a double thread through that and
it could rear itself in any way at any
moment so there was a in one episode the
news had broken about the governor from
South Carolina who was having affairs
with a woman in Argentina and was this
got revealed and it was embarrassing and
everyone in this governor of South
Carolina who no one had heard of before
became a household name I think this was
especially relevant to Stephen Colbert
because he's from South Carolina all
right
I missed that news story all right no I
mean I knew of it but I didn't preload
my utility belt walking into that
interview and he leads off by saying oh
you know I I just read recently that
that there was a survey conducted that
most people cannot name a living
scientist what do you have to say about
that and so I said I don't care if you
can name I don't care about names I care
about ideas I care about the science
itself and he said well but but really
though wouldn't isn't all that would
take is to have some scientist go to
Argentina and and the whole audience
started laughing and I said why are they
laughing no idea I'm saying holy [ __ ]
okay so I then I I had to go to plan B
and the plan B is
we'll laugh alongside the audience okay
and smile nod and then move the subject
forward preventing him from coming back
to it because I put something else on
the table that he then has to deal with
that was me
saving face rather that's my ego there
right rather than saying I have no idea
why you're all laugh and they didn't
have to explain it to me and then that
messes up the joke and so but I
successfully steered out of that out of
that mud slide right and kept going
forward so that was that was a mistake
because that was very current events and
I just missed it I had no excuse at all
there was another so that's just oh
another one I was a guest on D soos and
Miro these are two very hip hosts of a
talk show very very hip like complete
with hoodies and graffiti sprayed on
their jackets and I'm walking in there
with a sport coat and a button-up shirt
and no one in there is wearing a
button-up shirt not the production crew
nothing so I say damn I am I don't know
you know how am I gonna pull this one
off okay and so because I don't have
this one message delivered one way I try
to fit an audience right I mean that's
what you should do they have a following
and I'm a guest on their show let me try
to fit that environment so I'm in there
and they're asking very hip questions
and I am at the limits of my cool I
don't know if I can continue this I'm at
the limits and I see one of his wearing
a Yankee hat is he's from the Bronx I'm
from the Bronx and I'm a Yankee fan that
gave me some place to go in the
conversation keeping it buoyant and at
one point they asked me one of their ask
me oh by the way who's your favorite
member of the wu-tang clan there's like
oh okay I only know one member that
would tend so I'm just gonna say his
name and maybe that'll get me through
this I said oh the GZA of course great
great good answer
I don't know if they knew I was I was I
was at the cliff face right now so so
again the point is we're serving their
audience and to have some awkward
interview doesn't serve anybody you know
so now it's probably not we wanted me to
go with these answers right and I'll go
there so you talk about failures
I was never anyone's model student and
what is a model student it means you get
good grades in class and you you're not
disruptive well I had mediocre grades
and I was disruptive okay and disruptive
not in a bullying sense but just I had a
lot of social energy and I'd pass notes
among friends and you know I there's a
error when spitballs were in and I'd
shoot spitballs to the ceiling see how
long they would stick you know things
like that and that is not the conduct
that any teacher would say hey he'll go
far now here is the one of the
impressions that were false in The New
Yorker article it said that I was a
mediocre student okay but that was a
translation from I had mediocre grades
when I was anything but a mediocre
student right like I said I was part of
the astronomy club I'd taken extra
classes at the Museum I already knew I
was reading far more than anybody else
of my classmates I was visiting
observatories when were on a trips to
cities
I was very committed and very serious I
was into photography I set up my own
darkroom at home back when dark rooms
were saying I would take over a bathroom
that did one of our bathrooms didn't
have any windows I took that over I
prayed I I sold photos to the local
newspaper when I photographed graffiti
there was an anti graffiti movement and
so in my mind I was never a mediocre
student even though my grades were
mediocre but if you have the bias that
your grades are who you are then yes
you're gonna write a sentence in an
article he was a mediocre student
right and so it looks if I say to you
this person's mediocre student what are
you gonna think leo they're not really
interested and they don't even know if
school is for them
there's an entire impression that you
get if we're told this is a mediocre
student that was not me nothing could
have been farthest from the truth about
me okay and it's all the rest of the
stuff I did I wanted expeditions I got a
scholarship to go on an expedition to
study Stonehenge with other research
anthropologists and Stonehenge has
scientific value and so I brought
science my this is in high school while
I did this right and I also viewed a
total solar eclipse off the coast of
North West Africa and I was 14 when I
went I lied and told everyone I was 16
and I went alone brought my telescope I
had a scholarship to do that all of this
is going on all right and that's why I
was admitted at Harvard okay
Harvard didn't give a [ __ ] about scuse
me that's all right yes this is what's
going on in my life it means a door it
means I have ambitions it means I have a
mission statement for myself and what I
want to accomplish in life and if you
just want to go into the classroom and
take a test get a grade and have that be
the sole assessment of whether you think
someone is going to succeed fine but if
you also recognize that there are people
out there who get stuff done in their
lives then that gives you a hose to a
whole other category of person who's out
there
so did I learn anything from not being
any teacher's best student no cuz I was
self driven but it's not it's it's still
awkward and and uncomfortable to know
how driven you are but then not get
recognized for it and ultimately I was
recognized by the colleges that admitted
me so and then later on ik I made it
into tho something called the Harvard
100 which are is a list of the hundred
most influential living graduates and so
so I think they knew what they were
doing when they admitted me
and by the way they get more applicants
who are valedictorians of their high
school then there are slots in there
entering class so if they wanted to they
could just take every valedictorian but
they apparently and fortunately for me
see other things about a person that
they care about mm-hmm and and it seems
like your parents were also and I'm kind
of reading between the lines here but
supportive of you being ambitious and
self-motivated as an autodidact outside
of the classroom and not overly fixated
on grades within the classroom is that a
fair I wasn't
since I wasn't failing any classes they
were not concerned and my I got A's B's
and C's my whole life averaging a B
basically so there was it was not a
problem and my brother and sister needed
more sort of buoyant support from my
parents academically than I did so
looking back I think I was pretty easy
kid to raise all things considered right
so for example if I if I go out on a
Friday night and I come back late they
can't say why did you come back late you
have to come back earlier why well
because you could you could have been
studying no I was you know what my
grades are okay you know oh so what I
mean is my parents were not if I got a B
they're not asking how come it wasn't
today right or forgot a my is how come
it wasn't an a-plus that's not what kind
of parents they were as long as I was
progressing in school and moving through
and doing okay they were fine you have
an impressive memory one last thing
yeah so ask yourself suppose they were
high pressure parents with regard to
grades so there I am with my own sort of
photography business right and and I'm
in the astronomy club and this sort of
thing and they're saying we don't want
bees we want a z' then I have to cut
away those other activities to spend
more time in the books to get A's then I
would have had a z' and then nothing
else in my life would have developed and
that's an interesting trade-off one is
making of there
as a parent if you're gonna require
grades when they're time they might have
otherwise spent could have they could
have grown in other ways that are not
measured by grades but go on you you
might not have had time for developing
your ankle pick and wrestling as another
example just which we won't get into in
this conversation because I used to
wrestle I'd be a very self-indulgent but
those of you who are interested you can
follow up another time dr. Tyson was
also a very successful wrestler
I was I was best mitching well in high
school I was undefeated in high school
college was another matter I'm sort of
wrestling like corn-fed guys from the
Midwest yes tough breed tough I'm sure
we're like hauling cows from childhood
and that was a whole other whole other
level of commitment and and so I had a
losing record my all my years of college
I think my senior year I might have you
know been six and five or something but
I enjoyed the sport immensely whether or
not I was winning I'm I'm gonna I'm
going to show some restraint and in
jumping into wrestling for the rest of
this conversation that I solve I'll grab
the Lifeline back to my question about
memory what's indirectly about memory
you you seem to really have a knack for
remembering quotes facts figures all all
sorts of of data and and sayings I'm
curious if there are any particular
quotes that you think of often or live
your life by oh there any are thirty
favorite quotes that you come back to
often yeah one is by by um Ptolemy
Claudius Ptolemy who is a two thousand
years ago he was a Alexandria and
mathematician who wrote a book which was
the crowning achievement of a geocentric
universe of course the whole concept
wrong but it was interestingly wrong
right if you're gonna be wrong at least
be wrong in a way that stimulates
further research which is what that did
the translation of which which went into
Arabic a thousand years ago was called a
llama jest which when was translated
into Arabic and that title is now the
title that we now use for it because
that's the form in which it was most
remembered in other words it was most
widely distributed after it was
preserved in Arabic and then re
translated back into Latin and English
Almagest means the greatest so in there
in the margin of the manuscript he
writes oh by the way the planets we're
still not there movement in the night
sky was still not deeply understood the
planet would be moving sort of
right-to-left against the background
stars over the weeks it would slow down
and then go backwards oh my gosh we have
a word for that it's called retrograde
people actually thought the planets were
actually going backwards when well if
the whole world revolved around earth
yes they would be going backwards but
since that's not the case this
retrograde motion is just sort of an
illusion of who's moving to the left or
right as you go around one side of the
Sun versus the other but the here's the
quote when I trace at my pleasure the
windings to and fro of the heavenly
bodies I no longer touch earth with my
feet I stand in the presence of Zeus
himself and take my fill of ambrosia
that's one of my favorite is I have
beautiful feel that when I look up and
it's also it borders on spiritual right
he is invoking God in this case Zeus as
someone who he's hanging out enjoying
the the unfolding of cosmic events and I
don't count myself among the ranks of
the religious but when I look up and I
see mysterious things there's sort of a
a spiritual connectivity with the
unknown that courses through me and
where I feel exactly that I give just
while we're on it a couple more quotes I
happen to like wine you know wine
enthusiasts and so is a quote from
Galileo I have to paraphrase it forgive
me it's the Sun can keep the planets in
orbit on their appointed paths
yet somehow managed to ripen a bunch of
grapes as though it had nothing else in
the world to do that's fantastic
yeah wha-wha-wha on a roll at dawn Perry
on the monk who's as a very famous
Champaign named after him
I'm stumbled on this double fermentation
process where the first fermentation of
the yeast gets you alcohol from sugar
and then a second fermentation gives you
carbon dioxide which is the the bubblies
he does this by accident and then he
tastes it and his first comment was I
believe I am tasting the Stars there's
one other quote this is a quote where
this is why I know I'll never be a
novelist because this quote is just oh
my gosh I can't I can't do this this is
just too perfect okay here it is it's
from F scott Fitzgerald from from the
Great Gatsby and you know these are
party guy right okay the great Getwell
wealthy party guy
here's a quote in his blue Gardens men
and girls came and went like moths amid
the whispers the champagne and the stars
just like whoa okay that is I can't do
that
yeah sorry not the whispers among the
whisperings excuse me whispering smoke
whisperings the shame so the see the the
the the theme or the end the takeaway
that that I that that come to mind is
that you and I have to have some wine or
bubbly and talk about stars I mean
that's clearly the subtext here and so
but I don't want to credit credit for a
good memory
I don't know how it compares with the
average person's memory but I'd like
remembering things that matter to me
that have moved me it takes nothing to
remember a quote that moves you in this
moment I'm wearing a shirt with the
entire tract of desert darada printed on
it
old-timers might remember it from back
in the 70s it's this it's this manifesto
for how you might live one's life
written by Max or woman but that was
only discovered later it was originally
attributed to some anonymous monk that
because they found it in a church
sixteen hundreds in a desk drawer and
they figured it was from when the church
was founded but no it's more modest from
1927 MX Roman happens to be a rabbi very
different from a monk in the 1600s but
one of the lines is take kindly the
counsel of the year's gracefully
surrendering the things of youth I take
that to heart I used to dance I was a
performing member of three dance
companies there were college troops and
people say you know we have dances with
stars on TV why don't you do that what
don't you want to do that again no I'm
done dancing that I did that's a chapter
of my life I'm in a different chapter
now I don't have chapters of the past
that I then longed to relive in the
future for every chapter you longed to
relive you have not done enough with
your life in the present to continue to
grow who and who and what you are and
what you can be benefiting from the
wisdom that you
I'm elated over all the years you've
been alive since then so so this letters
book is a summation of wisdom a letter
is his wisdom and it's I could not have
written the letters book when I was
dancing and when I was dancing no one
was would have one of my books anyway
even if I did write one and so I have no
interest to do what I did in the past
when I'm doing something different now
and I'm really looking forward to
letters from an astrophysicist I
recommend everybody check it out and
I'll certainly be linking to that and
everything we've discussed in the show
notes including Ptolemy with a PT for
those people who want to look them up
but that'll go to show notes but all
potala Ptolemy and people can say hello
to you on Twitter at Neil Tyson face
monk Neil deGrasse Tyson Instagram also
at in the OL deGrasse Tyson this has
been so much fun
I really appreciate you making the time
to have this conversation well thanks
for your insightful and welcomed
questions I think they're all the right
questions in the right way giving me a
chance to say fresh things to a
listening audience so thanks my pleasure
is there anything else you'd like to to
say ask suggest any parting comments
before we wrap up no I see myself as a
servant of the public's curiosity so the
fact that you had interest in
interviewing me
meant that you felt that your fan base
you're following would have an interest
in me and so I'm flattered by that
consideration and I just hope I served
their curiosity or stoke security in
whatever ways that that are within my
abilities well you certainly stoked my
curiosity I have pages of notes and that
gives me certainly hope that that's the
case for a lot of people who will have
listened to this and be fun to see you
again in person sometime actually and
the course of that very much appreciated
thanks again you can
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email for me would
you enjoy getting a short email for me
every Friday and that provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
comm that's four hour work week com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoy it this
episode is brought to you by shipstation
if you've ever sold anything online or
if you sell anything online then you
know what a pain in the ass the shipping
process is it's time-consuming it's
expensive
you're always copying and pasting orders
from different sites trying to figure
out the best carrier so on and so forth
it's such a hassle and in a previous
life I shipped tens of thousands of
units overseas domestically overnight
ground every possible carrier it drove
me bonkers shipstation
was created to make your life easier I
wish I had had it when I was in the biz
so to speak it has the most five-star
reviews of any shipping software 4.9 out
of 5 for Magento users four point eight
out of five for Shopify users four point
five out of five for big commerce users
it goes on and on whether you're selling
on eBay Amazon Shopify or more than 100
other popular selling channels
shipstation lets you access all your
orders from one simple dashboard
shipstation works with all of the major
shipping carriers locally and globally
including FedEx UPS and the major local
couriers like us
yes shipstation will recommend the best
carrier for your needs so that you know
that you're always getting the best deal
they even offer discounts on shipping
costs that are available to say you as a
one-person shop that would normally be
thought of as reserved for large fortune
500 companies so there are a lot of
benefits no other shipping platform
makes shipping faster easier and more
affordable and right now to embarrass
your listeners get to try ship station
free for sixty days when you use promo
code Tim it's risk free you can start
your free trial without even entering
your credit card info just visit ship
station com click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in Tim
T I am that ship station comm enter
promo code Tim check it out ship station
comm promo code Tim this episode is
brought to you by helix sleep last year
I focused on dramatically improving a
few things surprise surprise
most notably the quality of my sleep
which seems to affect just about
everything this led me to revisit you
name it my daily routine morning routine
exercise diet all the way to what I
slept on and I ended up getting all new
beds here in Austin Texas including
mattresses from helix Slavin helix has
built a sleep quiz that takes two
minutes to complete and they use the
answers to match your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress whether you're a side sleeper
hot sleeper cold sleeper you like plush
you like firm with helix there's no more
guessing and more confusion just go to
helix sleep calm fort / Tim take their
two minutes sleep quiz and they'll match
you to a mattress that will give you the
best sleep of your life that is their
promise for couples helix can even flip
the mattress down the middle providing
individual support needs and feel
preferences for each side they have a 10
year warranty and you can test drive
your mattress for a 100 nights risk-free
right now helix is offering up to one
hundred and twenty-five dollars off of
all mattress orders check it out get up
to 125 off at helix sleep calm fall and
slash
Tim that's helix sleep calm for / Tim
for 125 dollars off your mattress order
tickle ik helix sleep calm forward slash
you